I showed how three rotation matrices multiplied together gives a single new
matrix. Interestingly enough, this resulting matrix R is, in fact, a rotation
matrix itself. Any number of rotation matrices multiplied together always
results in another rotation matrix. This resulting rotation matrix will have a
single specific axis and rotation angle. I have two questions for you. First of
all, can you multiply a series of translations together and get a single
translation matrix? Second, can you multiply a series of scales together and get
a single scale matrix? For example, say you apply a number of scales in a row to
an object. If you multiply all these scale matrices together, do you get a
single scale matrix? Or do you get something else?